hola buenas noches efectivamente han
dado en el punto es increíble realmente
imposible estamos hablando de esta
situación como una noticia estamos
hablando de una mujer y derecha con una
carrera muy interesante en su actividad
política que al mismo tiempo es muy
joven y que está haciendo digamos
algunos vídeos con sus amigas como una
persona de su edad sin hacer nada
indecoroso ni ilegal y de pronto es
noticias internacionales cierto mientras
tanto en el pasado hemos visto como
otros diarios políticos como el ejemplo
que todas las boris johnson que viola la
ley tiene actuaciones que además son
contrarias no solamente a la ley que él
mismo promulga sino al salud pública y
no recibe el mismo nivel de escrutinio
creo que nos nos invita a pensar qué es
lo que realmente está ocurriendo aquí
que realmente es lo que se está
discutiendo y cuáles son los mensajes
que estamos enviando al público eso sin
decir que parece también que parte del
mensaje es una contenida porque el joven
iba de fiesta mientras que algunos
ciudadanos reprocharon el comportamiento
de marín otros se publicaron vídeos
bailando en redes sociales para apoyar
la catalina hay una mala conducta de
esta líder en su opinión en absoluto al
revés yo creo que hoy lo que deberíamos
estar hablando a propósito de esto es
como efectivamente una persona joven que
además es mujer está asumiendo un rol de
liderazgo tan importante en un país que
adicionalmente en las últimas ese día
ahora ha tenido noticia frente a la
realidad digamos de seguridad que está
teniendo el continente propio de por no
decirlo el mundo ya en este momento lo
que podemos decir de nuestra primera
ministra de finlandia es que es una
mujer que está tomando riesgos vamos
lideresa y que al mismo tiempo el
escrutinio que está recibiendo es por
comportarse como cualquier otra persona
en su en su momento privado con una
persona de su edad entonces vale la pena
decir
que estas críticas nos parece que son
una cortina de humo realmente para un
poco bajar en la unlu con autoridad
frente a las decisiones que se están
tomando en fin lanza y es en nuestro
trabajo denunciar esas desigualdades de
género sin embargo está este último caso
de la última foto que trascendió que es
de julio dos mujeres desnudas besándose
con la bandera en la residencia oficial
porque esto constituye una ofensa porque
ella misma ofreció una disculpa diciendo
que era una imagen inapropiada
bueno podemos entender que de alguna
manera para algunas personas puede ser
una imagen apropiada para otras también
valdría la pena es bueno que pases una
pareja heterosexual estaría teniendo
también este tipo de escrutinio ese es
un poco como revisar cuál es el contexto
de la foto pero sobre todo darnos cuenta
que no es ella no estamos hablando de
ley actuar tenía un evento en la casa en
la casa privada o en la residencia y
algún hombre a tampoco sea responsable
como actúan las personas que están allí
aquí lo importante es identificar qué es
lo que realmente está detrás de estas
críticas que está recibiendo la primera
ministra